[Musique]
le 21 juillet 1969 l'astronaute neil
armstrong est le premier être humain
poser le pied sur la lune
[Musique]
pour le président john kennedy il était
important de battre le programme spatial
soviétique en pleine guerre froide
le succès d'apollo 11 a été suivie de
cinq autres missions lunaires dont
certaines ont séjourné jusqu'à trois
jours sur la surface de la lune c'était
il ya 50 ans
dans la mythologie grecque le dieu
apollon est associée au soleil artemis
et sa soeur et on l'associent à la lune
avec appolo on a marché sur la lune avec
artemis on vint s'installer sur la lune
en 2025 en trois étapes
plus tard cette année avec artemis 1 le
lanceur sls space launch system le plus
puissant de l'histoire décollera de cap
canaveral et emportera le vaisseau
spatial orion pour le tester sans
équipage à plus de 450 milles kilomètres
de la terre pour une mission de quatre à
six semaines avec orbite autour de la
lune
c'est avec artemis 2 et 3 que commencera
la participation du canada parce que
c'est mission environ des astronautes
vers et sur la lune et l'un d'eux sera
canadien
on a quatre astronautes actif en ce
moment à l'agencé spatiale canadienne
jean frédéric sont tous qualifiés pour
d'une science passer à l'avenir
le choix du canadien et des autres
astronautes américains et européens est
attendu l'an prochain
les astronautes irons plus loin qu'ils
ont été pendant les missions apollo
alors ce sera la première fois que des
humains iront autour de la lune derrière
la lune la face cachée aussi loin et
puis ils vont donc vérifier le
fonctionnement de tous les systèmes qui
vont permettre aux astronautes par la
suite de retourner sur la halle pour les
10 à 20 prochaines années on prévoit des
vols assez régulier à peu près une fois
par année vers la lune des missions de
plus courte durée au départ puis des
missions plus longues durées
puis les astronautes construirons une
station spatiale en orbite autour d'un
l'une appelée gateway la passerelle ça
va être un laboratoire d'expériences
scientifiques développement
technologique poste de contrôle aussi
pour les expériences et les déploiements
sur les lieux et c'est aussi une grande
collaboration internationale le canada
se joint aux américains aux européens ou
japonais pour faire partie de cette
aventure
le canada construit un nouveau bras pour
le gateway le bras canadien numéro 3 2
fois plus petit que les deux premiers
entièrement robotisée autonome canada
deux étaient assemblés par les
astronautes et entretenus par les
astronautes en ce que canada 3 pour
pouvoir se déployer tout seul
complètement prendre tous les morceaux
du système les installer sur get well
ghetto et sera la base de départ pour
des séjours de plus en plus long sur la
lune où sera installé une station
permanente où il faudra pouvoir se
déplacer
ce propos de cette loi a été utilisée
pour vérifier entre autres les
algorithmes de navigation autonomes pour
vérifier les concept d'opération quand
on contrôle à distance
et pour se déplacer il faudra avoir des
véhicules planétaire les fameux rover on
parle d'une mission vers les pôles donc
ce qui nous intéresse dans ce cas là
c'est les composés volatils donc l'eau
qui est prise sous forme de glace dans
le sol l'oxygène l'hydrogène on veut
aller analyser ça pour bien comprendre
la géologie d'une heure évidemment est
aussi pouvoir comprendre si un jour on
peut faire de l'extraction sur place
mais ton pour appuyer nos missions
un défi technologique deux compagnies
canadiennes travaillent sur des
prototypes siv en 28 jours terrestres
pour faire une journée l'une à 14 jours
de noir sont donc ça devient extrême
extrêmement froid exactement et puis il
faut réussir à survivre à sa fin
congelé à mort donc il faut le lendemain
matin réussir à se réveiller et
redémarrer
artemis vaste projet international en
partenariat avec l'industrie privée veut
explorer la lune et l'habiter pour
l'exploiter le prochain volet c'est le
volet commercial alors que là on y voit
de manière durable avec des partenaires
et éventuellement il y aura une économie
lunaire et des activités commerciales
aussi autour d'eux
mais ensuite la station lunaire n'est
qu'une étape dans l'exploration de
l'espace artemis vise plus loin la
planète mars plus facile à atteindre de
la lune que de la terre on va pouvoir
expérimenter des scénarios missions qui
vont nous permettre aussi d'envisager
des voyages vers mars la lune c'est
aussi un tremplin pour aller plus loin
dans le système solaire
[Musique]